-Our first guest tonight is
a legendary Emmy- and Academy
award-winning actress
you know from films
such as "Monster's Ball,"
"Die Another Day,"
and the X-Men franchise.
She both stars in and makes
her directorial debut
with "Bruised," which is
streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Immaculate sent you?
-Yeah.
-You used to be Jackie justice,
right?
-Still am.
-Oh, yeah.
We'll see.
-Please welcome to the show
Halle Berry, everybody.
Hello, Halle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello!
-It's so lovely to see you
again.
-Hi, Seth.
-I'm so happy to have you
on the show.
I wish you were here,
but you have a wonderful reason
for doing this remotely.
Tonight at the People's Choice
Award, you are going to win
the Icon Award -- be presented
with the Icon Award.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you.
Otherwise, of course,
I would be right there.
-A little bittersweet for me.
I was runner-up.
[ Laughter ]
Last year, too, so it's
really getting hard.
-I'll share it with you.
-Thank you.
First of all, it just must be so
nice to go to an award show
knowing in advance that you are
going to be receiving an award.
You don't have to be a nominee
through the first half
of the night.
-[ Laughs ]
That is a good feeling.
But see, now you know
you have to have a speech.
You know you have to
have something to say.
When you don't know if you're
gonna win, you can think,
"I don't really have to think of
something to say
'cause I might not win,"
so, you know.
-That's true. You cannot do that
move tonight where you get up
and you go, "Oh, my God,
I didn't write anything!"
[ Laughter ]
Very exciting, as well -- I'm
even maybe more jealous of this.
Not that you're winning
the award,
but your presenter is Cardi B,
who did a song on the album.
Collaborating with her
on this film,
was that the first time
you'd gotten to know her?
-Yes. I mean, I knew of her
and I've been a fan of her
since she came on the scene.
I mean, who hasn't?
I mean, she's just been
a powerhouse.
But it was our first time
collaborating
and it's just been a dream to
work with her
and put the whole album together
and just support these ladies
and have their sound be
a part of the film.
It's just been a dream-come-true
experience.
-The character you play is
what we've all come to
expect from you -- it's this
wonderful acting performance.
You play this broken,
very layered character,
but this is your first time
behind the camera.
I heard that
you don't actually like
watching yourself on camera.
Does that make directing
yourself almost impossible?
[ Laughter ]
-Not impossible to direct
but impossible to watch.
The edit was gnarly.
[ Laughs ]
I mean, I really got tired of
looking at my face
and looking at myself.
And I kept trying to cut myself
out, and my editor was like,
"You know, you have to stay
in this movie.
You're the protagonist."
[ Laughter ]
I kept saying, "But you don't
really need me here.
You don't need that shot on me
here."
It's really very hard for me
to watch myself.
-Were you surprised?
Having to revisit
your performances each day,
were you surprised at which ones
worked and which ones didn't
once you got a chance
to see them?
Or was it, as an actor,
did you think in your head,
"Oh, this'll be the one we use"?
-A little bit of both.
Because of the nature
of the movie,
it was a lower-budget movie,
so it's not like I had a lot
of choices to choose from,
if I'm telling you the truth.
I mean, some shots,
we only got two takes,
so I had one or two
to choose from.
So, you know, really didn't have
that problem necessarily.
-As someone who doesn't like
going back
and watching yourself,
does that mean --
Do you ever revisit
your old work?
Do you ever watch
old Halle Berry movies?
-No.
Sometimes when I'm watching,
I'm scrolling through television
and one comes up.
I literally am like,
"Aaah, God!"
[ Laughter ]
"No, get it off!"
No, I really -- it's painful.
No, I don't. I see them --
We do a press screening
so we can talk about it
at the junket,
I go to the premiere,
and then that's it.
I never see them again,
except this one.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
I heard you brought
your 13-year-old daughter
to watch sort of
early cuts of the film.
Was her eye helpful for you
and how did she react?
-Yeah, I wanted to show her
because this movie took almost
three years of my life
and she wanted to see, like,
"What have you been doing all
this time with your time, Mom?"
So I took her to see it,
and unfortunately,
I was doing a watch-down and
the color wasn't quite right
and she only got to see the two
scenes that I was most nervous
about, which were the two
love scenes in the movie
because those were two scenes
that could tell us very clearly
where we were
with our color grade.
And so that's all she got to see
and at the end, she was like,
"So, that's what you've been
doing for three years?"
[ Laughter ]
"Great. Great, Mom."
-"I need a mom!"
-I know.
-You're gallivanting around
doing love scenes.
-And one that's not confused.
Yeah.
-Another thing that has been
reported on a great deal,
you know, you play this sort of
an MMA-style fighter
who's returning to the ring.
You broke your ribs, real-life
broke your ribs very early
in filming and toughed it out,
which I imagine is probably
because you're an impossible
director to work with.
You have no respect
for your actors.
[ Laughter ]
-None, especially this one.
I was like, "Girl, tough that
[bleep] out."
[ Laughter ]
"I paid you a lot of money to be
here, come on, turn it out."
[ Laughter ]
No.
I had by that time,
after 2 1/2 years of training,
I felt like a fighter and I had
the fighting spirit inside me,
and quitting is just never what
fighters do.
I mean, they fight with
dislocated shoulders,
broken bones,
torn this, torn that,
and just quitting
is not an option.
It's gonna take a referee
to say stop, you know?
-And I guess for the method
actor performance,
it was probably maybe even
a little helpful to walk around
with a busted-up rib.
-[ Laughs ]
Mm, no, not so much.
[ Laughter ]
Couldn't breathe.
No, it wasn't so good.
-Yeah.
Look, I twisted my ankle once
and we canceled the show
for the whole week, so...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I get it.
-No judgment, Halle.
[ Laughter ]
You obviously did a lot of fight
training for other films,
"John Wick" being an example.
Did you have to do -- Like, did
you have a nice starting point
going into this or was it
building up back from zero?
-I had a good starting point
with "John Wick."
I'd never worked harder until I
started to train for "Bruised."
I had to do gun training
and some basic martial arts,
but with "Bruised," I had to
learn six different disciplines
that really weren't a part of
my "John Wick" training.
So, physically, I was
in a great shape to start
because I worked really hard
on that.
But all the things that I had to
learn to look like
a real MMA fighter and get all
that technical stuff in my body,
I just had to put in the work
and time to learn it.
-Well, it certainly shows.
Congratulations so much
on the film
and congratulations tonight.
I do want to let you go
so you can start
working on your speech.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you.
I'm gonna share it with you.
-Alright, thank you so much.
I will be watching,
and I would like you to --
Seth Adam Meyers.
If you can just use the whole
name, that'd be wonderful.
-Seth Adam Meyers. Okay, got it.
-Halle Berry, everybody!
"Bruised" streaming now
on Netflix.